ça fait deux ans que j'ai pas pris de
vacances
alors vous me réservez une petite place
sur la plage des salines et j'arrivais
nouveau job pour le comédien pascal
légitimus homme de service dans une
cantine
nous sommes à l'orphelinat saint-andré
dans les environs de paris c'est la
neuvième semaine de tournage des trois
frères le premier film des inconnus il
aura fallu deux ans de cogitation
intensive au trio comique pour écrire ce
scénario
alors évidement pas aller sous ces
histoires de donc de trois demi frères
forcément c'est les inconnus et on n'a
pas le même père mais la même mère qu'on
n'a jamais connu donc nous avons vécu un
petit peu la dass au niveau de l'enfance
et ses trois frères se retrouvent chez
un notaire parce qu'un jour ils
apprennent avec une lettre officielle
qu'ils ont un héritage de leur mère
justement et donc c'est la rencontre de
trois univers trois mondes différents
qui vont s'affronter se confronter
s'aimer se détester pendant une heure
une heure et demie ah ça c'est un
monsieur mathieu qui vient dé il vient
des îles aussi donc on essaie de prendre
quelques immigrés dans le tournage parce
qu'il ya un quota de deux techniciens et
ça nous était imposé notre région si
vous êtes imposé le quota et le
troisième qui n'est pas là on essaie de
le virer depuis six ans
on retrouvera l'esprit des inconnus sur
le côté quand même la critique sociale
la comédie l'humour bien sûr un peu de
poésie et puis je tiens à rassurer tout
le monde je pense qu'on a mis tous les
ingrédients pour que ça fonctionne au
niveau de l'humour surtout il avait
redonné envie que l'on prend pas ainsi
trop minable les trois chacun leur façon
ces trois sympathiques minable ddd paumé
je
oui c'est indispensable
on est trois minable qui essayons de se
la jouer parce que par manque affectif
parce qu'on n'a pas connu notre mère
donc on va essayer de retrouver cette
famille qu'on avait perdu ça c'est très
important
depuis deux décennies on s'est rendu
compte que la génération qui arrive
maintenant si une génération de divorcer
et que il ya un manque affectif énorme
ça on a toujours su c'est ça date
et c'est vrai qu'on avait envie de
parler de ça tout simplement
l'expérience j'ai pas d'enfant j'ai un
métier d'avenir
c'est une étape logique parce qu'on
avait envie de faire autre chose c'est
vrai qu'on a touché un petit peu à tout
entre le disque la télé la vidéo le
théâtre c'est une évolution naturelle
simplement parce que bon on avait envie
de varier les plaisir tout simplement
c'est une envie de jouer la comédie
différemment de toucher une technique
plus complexe qu'est le cinéma quand
même
mais en fait c est un film j'espère fête
sympa vous avez des extraits non ça vous
a plu
beaurevoir j'ai travaillé rendez vous en
octobre alors vivre sans l'autre
[Musique]